hey guys how's it go and I'm just saying
welcome to my kitchen this is something
that a lot of you probably never seen
unless you watch my vlogs guess what
today fending phone when you're watching
it March fourth is national pound cake
day so what better day to celebrate than
make a pound cake so in all of my years
of being alive I never actually knew why
they called it pound cake it's because
they use a pound of each ingredient of
flour sugar butter and eggs the only
problem is the recipe says you need to
use a mixer and guess but I don't have a
mixer have a pound cake day let's do
this we're here with my blender and I've
also make this pound cake I have my
recipe on my iPad the first thing I need
to do is preheat the oven okay assuming
I just push the button to stop push push
what it says I need three sticks of
butter well I have that right here it's
telling me I need to cream the butter
out of having that but but I do know how
to do is put things in a blender you're
not a whole stick these are like little
baby sticks and to the blender you go do
you want to have a heart attack today
because if you do you're gonna eat my
pound cake I don't have a mixer why
would I have a mixer I don't cook I
don't bake
I can make eggs oh don't you worry don't
you worry child I'm gonna make a pound
cake for you okay let's do our first a
first blend and see what happens
this blender is made to do stuff like
blend
no get in here gonna have to ask you to
please blend this sucks what's next
because this was not working out like I
planned at sugar one cup at a time no no
let's put you ahead probably gonna need
the one egg in there do
oopsies do egg whoa maybe I'll just have
another stick of butter can't hurt right
just isn't working right another Reagan
one out of the shell
doesn't matter it's gonna get all around
it up mixed it up real good
because it ease to the bottom how am I
gonna get three got some flour in here
it's like a soupy thanks guys this is
not gonna work out right now for our
first cup of flour let's hope this
blends man let's just go for two one
more cup of flour are you boiling I hope
not
you just really need I need a pad sprite
to this this is really seem to be doing
much so uh think I have all my
ingredients in there TSP of butter
flavoring I don't have that but what I
do have is but this has a pound cake on
it so I thought I pound cake on it of
course isn't a tablespoon 1t okay put
into a greased bundt pan and bake an
hour I have to bake it for an hour
Vitamix is no longer turning on no big
deal okay
first to the cup sure it's a dry
measuring cup I don't care how much is a
cup one cup oh my
I'm really really unsure of everything
that I did today let's see if we can't
get you to work again the ovens
preheated life is good yeah I'm gonna
get you really really greased up for our
mix into V cake oh boy you've got some
problems here this is not mixed up right
oh look at that
actually doesn't look too disappointing
I'm proud that I broke a Vitamix
seven-year warranty just got the last
week there's an open crevasse I was
stuck my camera in a preheated oven so I
could get a shot of me putting the cake
in bad idea
Oh things are
happening is there a rack what I'm
supposed to put it on whatever
all right I'll set a timer somebody set
a timer hour in ten minutes
it'll be Judgment Day I never want to
cook again so while I wait for my cake
doo doo it's baking I'll show you guys
what I bought I bought some eyes to put
on it and some cookie icing because
there's no way that I'm even gonna
attempt to make icing especially after
this disaster that ensued No
look what we have here in the oven
shining it's shimmering I think it's a
little crispy and I would potholder what
do I have I have another mix comparable
maybe put on a plate am I supposed to
flip it like this
stand there guy is a pound cake isn't
yeah should I cut these little edges off
here's the first taste this is the first
taste
it's have a really really good I'm in
something right
oh my god it's actually really good
probably because there's another butter
in there me to go to cardiac arrest
after that little nibble we've got our
eyes we've got our cookie icing I cut
this champion cookie I say cookie icing
just gonna dribble it all along the cake
I am a baker I don't even need to cut
into it more gone you're don't look
tough I've never made anything in my
life
oh hey Justine here's a good idea while
I put some eyes on your pound cake okay
I'm just gonna nibble away at these
sides all right so here's my pound cake
it has eyes and it's actually really
good I cannot believe that I made
something with my own two hands
that taste good don't forget to like
this video because if you don't like
this I'm gonna be really sad because
this is an accomplishment I'll have to
call my mom a dollar to like it because
I don't think she's ever seen me cook
anything now I need to get a mixer I'll
see you later I can't shop anything